&gt;&gt; We can think of negative x over 8 as x divided by negative 8, since the
negative sign can go either with the numerator or the denominator. It just
belongs to the fraction as a whole. That means to get x by itself, you just need
to multiply both sides by negative 8. On the left side, that leaves us with x.
On the right side, we have negative 16. But, just like before, we have to flip
the sign direction. We get x is less than negative 16. As always, I'm going to
check my solution with a number line. X is less than 16 is this region over
here. Let's pick one value inside this region, and see if it satisfies this
inequality. Negative 20 is over there, so negative 20 over negative 8 is just 5
over 2, or 2 and a half. 2 and a half is greater than 2, so we're good on that.
Now let's pick one value to the right, in the region where values that we plug
in should not satisfy this inequality. I'll pick zero, since it's always my
favorite number to pick. Zero divided by anything, including negative 8, is just
equal to zero. And zero is not greater than two, so this also confirms our
solution set. So we can see that whether we divide or we multiply both sides of
an inequality by a negative number, we have to switch the sign of the
inequality. Remember, division and multiplication are very, very intimately
linked.